mayor Pete Pete Buddha judge suddenly
ended his presidential campaign
yesterday the decision may have been
made very quickly because there are many
Pete surrogates and campaign staff who
heard about it not from the campaign not
from their employer but rather through
media reports about Buddha judge ending
his campaign and this is from a
calculated strategic perspective very
clearly a move meant to help Joe Biden
by consolidating centrist support around
Joe the question is whether it will work
and we'll talk about that in a moment
Buddha judge got the most delegates out
of Iowa currently third in the delegate
counts at 26 delegates but was not
looking good for tomorrow's Super
Tuesday contests at all so there are a
few considerations here but clearly this
happened in consultation with the Biden
campaign as nobody else at this point is
really viable other than Bernie Sanders
unless something changed radically
during tomorrow's Super Tuesday
elections which we'll talk about one
thing for Budaj edge alone is since he's
so young it's probably better to drop
out before doing poorly on Super Tuesday
then after so that in four years or
eight years if he wants to run again he
can say listen I did well in those first
primaries I didn't suffer any
embarrassing defeats like would be
probably happening if you were to stay
in until Super Tuesday and that's about
Pete and Pete alone now the second part
is the Biden piece does this help Joe
Biden lots of people are posting polling
data from example from morning consult
saying if you look at the second choices
of Pete supporters it's not clear it
helps Biden for example if you look at
morning consult numbers that say well
Bernie benefits the most because 21
percent of Pete's voters would go to
Bernie second 19 percent would go to
Biden 19 percent would go to Warren 17
percent would go to Bloomberg what this
ignores is that just because when Pete
is in the race you say well Warren's my
second choice as 19 percent did if Pete
drops out you
automatically go to Warren and in other
words if you if you like Pete and Pete
drops out and your second choice is
Warren but you are able to see the
numbers and you realize Warren's not
viable you don't necessarily go and vote
for Warren you might vote for someone
else so the point is it's not clear to
me how much we are going to glean about
exactly how much this helps Biden versus
somebody else until we actually wait and
see what happens tomorrow if I had to
guess the most likely analysis to me is
that this helps Biden and Bernie roughly
equally at the national level a couple
of points to each but it will really
come down to the state-by-state impact
because not only are the state numbers
very different depending on the
demographics of each state in terms of
how much support Joe Biden has the other
consideration is Warren is close to
viability in a few different states so
we'll look at this in a moment but
Warren is at 13 in Texas and 14 in Utah
if Warren gets a couple of points in
each of those states thanks to Pete
Budaj edge dropping out she could end up
getting some delegates instead of none
by reaching the viability threshold and
that will definitely hurt Bernie because
he's the one who if he doesn't get to
50% plus one by the convention may lose
the nomination so III think that we're
gonna have to wait and see what the
actual effect is but if I had to say I
think that this is going to help Biden
in a direct way by giving him a little
bit of Pete support but may actually
hurt Bernie by dividing the number of
Delegates
among more people on Super Tuesday we
will see real quick I want to tell you
about a YouTube channel called up flip
they're friends of our show you can
check them out by going to david
pakman.com slash up flip the link is
down below underneath the video every
week up flip publishes a new video where
you get to meet an entrepreneur learn
about the business they built see what
it's like to live a day in their shoes
in that business I love learning about
small business owners the steps they
took to become successful that's why I
love the content on up flip you'll get
an exclusive look at some really fast
businesses each entrepreneur has many
valuable insights and strategies to
share about how to build and maintain a
successful company I would highly
recommend their two-part series on lean
manufacturing which itself is a really
interesting concept that's all about
sort of minimizing waste maximizing
efficiency and up flip breaks it all
down you can get to their channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
the link is right below this video make
sure you subscribe to their channel and
click that Bell icon so you'll be
notified when they upload new videos